this culture-rich city yesterday shared
a prestigious label
with india's taj mahal and the ancient
pyramids of egypt
today liverpool's world heritage status
was scrapped an announcement that left
this city feeling humiliated
and angry it's steeped in history you've
only got look at the buildings behind
you
and losing that why i'm shocking really
the fact that it was like that
that's what kept liverpool liverpool in
a sense and the fact that now that we've
lost it it's like
it's disappointing disappointing it's
going to become
very similar to other places and lose
its unique
qualities unesco
concluded liverpool's waterfront was
destroyed by new and modern buildings
and at this derelict site everton is set
to build a new
500 million pound football stadium for
the body
that was the final nail in the coffin
david who first campaigned for this
status 20 years ago
says the world heritage remits have been
restrictive
and delisting liverpool now is the right
move
it was always represented a really big
hurdle that anything that you wanted
wanted to get done went through the
usual planning proposals but there was
always the consideration
of what world the world heritage
organization would have to say about it
and their guidelines all weren't ever
very clear
of what they wanted it was always clear
what they didn't want
for the best part of 20 years the city
has been recognized for its role
as a major trading power during the
british empire
and the architectural beauty of its
waterfront
but unesco's decision gives liverpool
the ignominious distinction
of being only the third place to lose
its status
in 50 years claire runs culture
liverpool
she's disappointed the un's organization
hasn't visited here
for more than a decade there are ways to
do heritage
in a really contemporary exciting
fashion and i just don't think that
if you don't visit here and speak to
people face to face
and see what this beautiful city is how
can you make those judgments on a city i
don't
kind of get that really liverpool has
been on a long and winding road
of regeneration and renovation it's
brought huge confidence
and an unrivaled vibrance to this city
and whilst the coveted world heritage
status
may have put them back on the map
without it
people here will just have to let it be
in zaman rashid sky news
liverpool